السوداني كله معالي يعني انا ازمه الوقود
ازمه الخبز وزمه المول وازمه للكهرباء
يعني عندنا اطفال يعني عندنا اطفال وناس
تعبانه وناس عيانه حرب جاءت على كل شيء
مواجهه المسلحه هنا في السودان بين قوات
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع تدخل
اسبوعها الرابع وتلقي بظلالها على شتى
مناحي الحياه فمحطات الوقود الفارغه هذه
تشهد انقطاعا في الامداد منذ بدء
المواجهات بينما تصطف هذه السيارات في
محطات اخرى يقول اصحابها انها تعمل بما
توفر فيها من مخزون
يعني حتى الليله عامل بلديه
وعلى امل ان يحصل هؤلاء على حصه وقود
تسيرهم لايام افترشوا الارض لايام
فعنبا بكر الذي يعول اسره ويعتمد في دخله
على ناقله مواصلات داخليه يشتكي هو الاخر
من ازمه الوقود التي عطلته عن العمل ربما
والبلد كلها يعني سوق اسود
يشتغلوا كيف الاسود بيجي من وين
ظروف الناس تعبانه شديد يعني حتى لا
الواحد
الشعب عشان انت تشتري جهاز بالغالي الشعب
يعني قدره عشان يدفع ويجر زياده وليس عن
ما بكر وحده من تاثر فهناك المئات بل
الالاف ممن تهدد هذه الازمه حياتهم
واستقرارهم واجبتنا وحده في اليوم ناكلها
الناس واحده في اليوم بس دي عيشه ويعزي
المواطنون هذه الازمات الى الانفلات
الامني الكبير الذي تشهده البلاد منذ
اسابيع مما ادى لانقطاع سلاسل الامداد
واستمرار عمليات السلب والنهب التي طالت
كل شيء
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات